We've looked at creating modules and
controllers, and
applying them to templates using Angular
specific attributes, called directives.
But how does Angular actually make
the connection between the data
and the template?
When data changes in the website.
How does it update in the controller?
It all depends on Angular scope.
Angular scope is an object that
refers to an applications data.
It's the bridge between the template and
the controller.
And is the vehicle for
Angular's two-way data binding.
Data gets set initially
in the controller,
then when the engine controller
directive is added to the template.
The template now has a context for
its expressions.
When the expressions change in
the template, the controller is updated.
Let's see all this in action.
See how Angular added
an ng-scope class to this div?
When Angular compiled this template,
it solved this directive.
And created a scope object that's
associated with this element.
So when it came to
the expressions in the template,
it could resolve them from the scope.
Checking the scope for
the divs shows us a lot of information.
The scope has an ID.
It also has a parent scope.
Inside our parent scope is our
menu property with the data from
the controller.
In the list of properties on
the scope object is $$watchers.
Watchers.
This is a list of things that angular
is watching for, for changes.
There is one watcher for
each expression.
Here's the one to watch the menu
image property for changes.
If Angular sees a change
in one of the watchers,
then it will update the property in
either the controller or the template.
At first, it's hard to understand
how two-way data binding works
between templates and
controllers in Angular.
Scope is the key that
binds them together and
performs updates when
either side changes.